- New economic data paint
a grim picture of March
as the country came to a standstill.
Business executives tell President Trump
that a key component to
reopening the economy
is a lot more testing.
The governor of New York says he's signing
an executive order that
will require people
to wear a face covering in public.
I'm Shelby Holliday, and
here are your coronavirus
headlines from the Wall Street Journal.
U.S. industrial production
fell 5.4% in March.
It's the biggest drop in measured factory,
utility, and mining production since 1942.
Retail sales, which include a measure
of purchases at stores,
bars, and restaurants,
fell 8.7% in March from a month earlier.
It's the biggest month-over-month drop
since records began in 1992.
These historic lows are the result
of the pandemic affecting
factories, malls,
restaurants, and other businesses.
Weekly jobless numbers
will be released today,
and the number of Americans
seeking unemployment
benefits is expected
to surpass 20 million.
Business leaders told President Trump
that his administration must dramatically
ramp up coronavirus testing,
according to people
familiar with the matter.
The executives said that
tests were necessary
to make Americans feel confident enough
to resume their normal lives.
A White House spokesman
declined to comment
on the conversation.
Trump recently announced that executives
from companies like General Motors, Apple,
and McDonald's are all part of a new
task force to reopen the economy.
The president is set to
release new guidelines today
about restarting the country
by first opening up states
with the least coronavirus cases.
It will ultimately be up to governors
to decide when to open their states.
- All people in public must have a mask--
- [Shelby] In the hardest-hit U.S. state,
New York Governor Andrew Cuomo announced
a new face mask rule
that will kick in Friday.
People will be required to wear
face coverings in public settings,
where they can come into
contact with others,
like in grocery stores, or when
using public transportation.
Coverings include medical masks,
as well as bandanas or scarves.
Cuomo said there could
eventually be penalties
for people who don't
comply with the order.